and these cages are [ __ ] metal and
and features like that when I was a kid
I probably would be one I feel like I
should do that in a degree become a
teacher just so I can not give a [ __ ] if
I get fired always have YouTube to fall
back that's a plan right but I now have
a plan fist fight so fist fight stars
Charlie Day and ice cubes are both
teachers in this high school is the last
day of school for this year the students
are pranking everyone they're being
dicks charlie day plays the nice teacher
he's spineless he's a bit of a weasel he
plays Charlie day playing a teacher he's
exactly that Ice Cube not gonna lie ice
cube plays ice cube playing a teacher
he's exactly that he's the hard core
teacher who straight-up has control of
his classroom long story short Charlie
days character snitches on ice cubes
characters so ice cubes character gets
fire two ice cubes like I'm gonna
fistfight you after school at 3:00 p.m.
so the movies building up to that and
Charlie dates kind of freaking out about
it and here we go shenanigans yeah we
have ourselves a comedy a comedy that
it's not blessed your gut belly laughing
it's not like I walked out of this movie
going this is the funniest comedy I've
seen in quite some time but this fight
made me chuckle and I enjoyed watching
it and that ain't nothing for a comedy
what I like about it funny enough is a
comedy with this premise or a lot of
comedies in general when you have the
spineless character who ultimately he's
taken on this thing that's so much
bigger than him and he's freaking out
about it by the end of the movie he'll
pretty much be the spineless character
again but maybe he'll learn a thing or
two who knows this will be straight-up
had character progression it's like
Charlie Day starts learning he starts
growing a bit of a spine search standing
up to people by the end of the movie he
has there's an arc to him mostly [ __ ] I
didn't think that would happen and it
did it's not always even sometimes like
oh he learned he grew spot okay he's
kind of spineless now again but
ultimately if there's a graph like it
would have its ups and downs as it goes
up also Charlie day is good at playing
that really loud kind of sketchy weird
weaselly character and I cube is good at
playing you ice cube play the hardcore
in-your-face teacher kind of feels like
he could play like the police chief in
21 Jump Street I feel like ice cubes
careers ultimately comprised of all
right ice cubes going to be the hard
core guy we're going to put ice cube up
against some spineless Weasley character
near the very end there's a thing that
Charlie Day has to do that is on a stage
I was dying I was laughing very hard
some of the pranks from students are
playing
pretty funny some of the pranks Alec and
whatever some of them are just
ridiculous this whole premise is
ridiculous there's no way that these
teachers are going to be in this
situation to have it play out to
fruition without getting arrested or
fired there's no way these students can
do what they do without getting expelled
or probably also arrested vandalism is I
think folks it's not just a prank
basically got a suspend your disbelief
on a good 60 foot 70 98 percent of this
movie we can do that you might actually
walk out of this movie I enjoyed it this
really doesn't really stand out at the
high school comedy that centers around a
couple of teachers not students so since
I didn't break much ground but I enjoyed
it I'm not going to write home about it
but I will say I enjoyed it so this
fight is a good time no alcohol required
and this review is brought to you by
audible follow the links below to
audible.com slash John's and get
yourself a 30-day free trial to browse
their empire of audio titles I
recommendation star wars catalyst solid
on right there does a good job at
filling in the gaps of what happened
before rogue one of Star Wars story if
rogue one a Star Wars story had an
opening crawls out of it so again follow
the link below to get your 30-day free
trial and get your Star Wars on or
whatever audiobook you want whispering
sweet nothings in your ear okay so this
fight have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever your thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]